[موسيقى]
نعلم ان الصيام مفيد جدا
لمريض السكر او غير مريض السكر وهنالك
فوائد صحيه مثبته علميا لكن هنالك جزء من
مرضى السكر
يجب ان لا يصومه وذلك لانه عندهم
مضاعفات متعلق بمرض السكر او نتيجه لطبيعه
الادويه اللي بياخدوها اللي ممكن تسبب
انخفاض في مستويات سكر الدم مع الصيام او
ارتفاع سكر الدم كثيرا اثناء فتره الليل
او اثناء الصيام وكذلك المرضى اللي عندهم
مضاعفات من مرض السكر او المرضى اللي
بيستخدموا ادويه الانسولين او المرضى كبار
السن كذلك لا ينصح انهم يصوموا اذا كان
عندهم مرض سكر هنالك مضاعفات معينه اذا
كانت موجوده يجب تجنب الصيام
مرض الفشل والكلوي المسبب بمرض السكر ومرض
اعتلال الاقدام المتقدم والمرضى اللي
بياخدو ادويه اخرى معقده بالذات اذا كان
عندهم مرض فشل عضله القلب نتيجه احتشاء
عضله القلب وانسداد الشرايين المتقدم
واللي بيخدم اجواء كبيره من الادويه
[موسيقى]
ينصح في العاده بتناول الكربوهيدرات
المعقده
ويجب ان تقسم بين الافطار والسحور وكذلك
الاكل اللي في
الياف عاليه لانه بيحتفظ بالسوائل في
الجسم وكذلك يساعد على هضم
الاكل انواع الاكل الاخرى يجب كذلك تناول
بعض البروتين اذا كان في وجبه الفطور او
في وجبه السحور
ومن المهم جدا
سماع نصيحه الطبيب والاخذ بالرخصه
[موسيقى]